c'était un vrai engagement en fait ça a
changé un peu le les outils là en
l'occurrence avait permis de changer
l'angle
[Musique]
un aéroport d heathrow
je pars de londres j'ai passé deux jours
vraiment incroyable avec microsoft est
la question qui se pose c'est comment
microsoft peut changer le monde alors
microsoft va pas changer le monde avec
une baguette magique comme harry potter
une baguette de sorcier ou avec un
gadget type james bond
non microsoft va changer les choses
vraiment différent donc il va le faire
on le prenons vraiment à la base du
problème c'est à dire
nous voilà à londres l'idée aujourd'hui
c'est de parler d'eux et aix et la
technologie et l'éducation
le bet 2019 à londres et je vais vous
montrer des choses juste incroyable
autour de l'éducation
ce que fait une marque comme microsoft
pour apporter des outils hyper
perfectionner pour l'éducation
c'est franchement un truc hyper cool
parce que ça permet de faire rentrer la
technologie dans les écoles et sur hyper
hyper honoré parce que dans les médias
influenceurs de france et que moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
ça c'est un changement
ça c'est une révolution je vous explique
pourquoi et là mais je pense quoi bush
situe le boucher soit
voilà quand tu vas à gauche eva gauche
en fait il faut comprendre ici avec
toutes les questions d'éducation qui
sont prêts sur le béton soit avec
microsoft plein d'autres entreprises
c'est qu'en fin de compte l'éducation
c'est 1 39 mais qu'elle soit qui est
plutôt verticale de l'enseignant envers
l'élève katia un vrai changement avec
une numérique est une nouvelle fois sont
déductibles nouvelles façons de
transmettre les savoirs et ce qui est
très intéressant est ce qu'on voit ici
aujourd'hui c'est qu'avec l'arrivée
bienvenue méric
c'est vraiment une vraie révolution qui
opère parce que d'une la façon de
transmettre le savoir n'est pas du tout
la même et surtout les outils
technologiques permettent de le faire de
façon vraiment différente et surtout ne
plus vraiment avoir de
laissés-pour-compte de personne de côté
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je m'appelle laurent je suis au comité
de direction chez microsoft en france et
je m'occupe de croix trois grands
domaines d'activité
ok les ministères collectivités locales
et puis certain nombre d'établissements
publics qui auraient le monde de la
santé et le monde de l'éducation
j'ai aujourd'hui on est au pet parfait
justement m c éducation technologie ce
qu'on appelle la head tech alors il peut
y avoir un peu une nébuleuse autour de
ça parce que c'est pas forcément tous
qu'il apparaîtra au grand public moi ce
que j'aimerais vraiment comprendre c'est
qu'est ce que fait microsoft du point de
vue les dix questions on travaille un
peu à tous les niveaux d'accord primaire
de ensuite collèges lycées et supérieur
ok il ya beaucoup de choses à faire
parce que le monde dans lequel on vit
c'est un monde numérique prendre une
place de plus en plus importante et en
fait toute la question c'est comment on
accompagne les profs qu'on pas forcément
été formés à cette époque là ça à
s'emparer de ces technologies la
préparer les élèves
deuxième sujet c'est on se rend compte
que les méthodes pédagogiques doivent
évoluer parce qu'il hier c'était un
enseignement très
top dang très décent dans le bronx est
très article très verticale là où c'est
une nouvelle technologie nécessite un
peu des compétences différentes et
capacité à travailler en groupe la
capacité à être épanoui à s'engager à
prendre le risque de se planter et à
prendre part le par l'échec sanxay des
conséquences très graves
et puis ensuite un savoir utiliser les
outils et les techno
qui sont ensuite utilisés dans le monde
professionnel mais finalement il ya
plein d'aspects différents
alors là on est sur le stand une
entreprise qui s'appelle éclats sous
serre ça c'est super intéressant parce
que ce qui vous propose c'est de
numériser tous les livres et de les
avoir directement incorporées dans des
tablettes dans des smartphones dans des
grands écrans dans tout ce que vous
voulez celui sont comme ça hyper
intéressante pourquoi
pour plusieurs raisons la première ça
permet d'apporter des livres à tous les
enfants sans avoir à galérer dont vous
pouvez voir plusieurs bouquins a
forcément les vivres vous allez les
activer sa fait que les écoles qui les
achètent cachets des licences pour des
classes pour des multi utilisateurs
donc ça c'est intéressant ça permet de
réduire aussi le coup de papier donc
d'arrêter un peu la déforestation alors
c'est par green non plus on va pas se
mentir parce carrière il va y avoir des
serveurs à dire la date a donc et une
pollution
d'une certaine manière mais si on peut
arrêter la déforestation par rapport à
ça franchement c'est un poteau c'est
très très très intéressant et puis
troisième point qui est vraiment
bénéfique c'est ça évite les sacs très
lourd un peu comme ça je sais pas si
vous êtes parent ou vous soumettez le
quand vous étiez enfant mais on a
toujours des cartables hyper lourd avec
des bouquins et nord est ont dit tiens
j'ai pris le match oubliant livre de mac
nerfs jubilee de mad gmat aujourd'hui la
livre de matt vous l'avez en permanence
avec vous soit dans votre smartphone
soit directement à l'école c'est
intéressant et là où on va encore plus
loin
si vous pouvez ensuite faire des
annotations directement vous pouvez
rajouter du contenu pour interagir
directement ya plus de papier pouvez
faire vos devoirs directement dessus
pour faire une interro dessus vous
l'envoyer directement à votre propre
carrière dit corrige sais pas mais
vraiment dématérialisée et à la limite
d'ajouter des solution plus intéressante
parce que l'école vous de l'avoir en
permanence avec vous où que vous soyez
dans les transports en commun et on peut
imaginer plein plein plein plein de
choses à dire là dessus alors c'est pas
parfait on les sent les écrans
ça s'est souvent il ya une fatigue
oculaire ça c'est évident mais en tout
cas c'est une avancée qui est assez
intéressante les points vraiment très
bénéfique
il ya aussi quelques points négatifs
sont assez prometteur
[Musique]
on réfléchit beaucoup sur qu'est ce qui
fait que les élèves sont beaucoup plus
engagés on réfléchit on en parlait tout
à l'heure sur l'émotion des élèves
pendant la classe l'émotion des propres
et comment on peut arriver à créer un
climat qui fasse que les uns et les
autres les enseignants comme les élèves
soient beaucoup plus épanouie parce que
finalement on se rend compte que de la
confiance en soi va résulter la capacité
à prendre des risques à se planter à
travailler en groupe parce que demandent
ces nouvelles technologies qui nécessite
d approche un peu différente un peu
triste à normes comme dans les startups
quoi de la même façon plus rôle du
manager il est en train de changer dans
l'entreprise hier le manager c'est l
expert oui c'est lui qui savait expliqué
qui transmettait son savoir faire
aujourd'hui le manager se côtoient un
coach qui révèle qui permet d'aider les
collaborateurs à s'épanouir et bien
quelque part je pense que le métier de
le professeur d'enseignant il est en
train de changer de la même façon
évidemment il ya cette dimension d'
expertise mais dans la dimension des
expertises savoir générer langage manche
ses élèves
c'est un élément hyper importante ça va
devenir prépondérant dans la pédagogie
amener l'élève à venir s'alimenter de
contenu plutôt que de le lui donner
probablement une
un des enjeux les plus forts en termes
de transformation alors c'est peut-être
une vue personnel
c'est passionnant tout cas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donc toi on va parler d'apprentissage
avec la réalité milk de windows
vous connaissez déjà bon là la réalité
virtuelle vous passez un peu le casque
et les contrôleurs vous connaissez et là
on va l'appliquer directement au monde
de l'éducation on a effectivement un
enseignant dans un cadre d'une vieille
bibliothèque qui va effectivement vous
parlez vous expliquer les choses alors
je les tester on est plus sur un côté un
peu
archéologie on a un vieil os de
dinosaures on va pouvoir le manipuler
tous les côtés essayer de comprendre
réellement quelle bête c'était qu'est ce
qu'ils faisaient à quelle époque y
vivent et on voit qu'une solution qu'on
a beaucoup pour quelque chose de très
fun très funky on peut l'utiliser pour
l'éducation on peut le trouver des
usages vraiment vraiment pertinents
c'est un exemple un peu concret pour
vraiment illustré cette façon les autres
pour les moyens une histoire qui m'a
marqué c'est à fougères en bretagne un
prof de techno qui a décidé de
mossé avec une de ses collègues prof de
latin qui elle connaît rien à la techno
oui et lui dire chiche on va aller
ensemble vas-y tape là on va aller
enseigner le latin avec minecraft
imagine donc que tu dis minecraft qu'est
ce que tu veux faire et en fait ils sont
rendus compte que en amenant les enfants
l'âge de la 5e à reconstruire un forum
finalement il appréhender des concepts
qui se mettaient à comprendre des mots
appréhender le vocabulaire et puis
surtout avoir un niveau d'engagement
complètement différent
avec les enfants au bout de deux ans et
avec du recul la prof de latin s'est
retrouvé avec des élèves qui étaient pas
loin d'être en échec scolaire en fin de
primaire qui va souffler un peu en
sixième se retrouver hyper motivés pour
son cours de latin local a été hyper
surprise pour aller finalement c'est ce
pas forcément ceux qui étaient le plus à
l'aise dans les résultats scolaires et
dans les notes qui se retrouvaient à
être les plus assidus les plus motivés à
son cours de l'attaqué
et puis et puis ensuite en fin d'année
au moment du voyage scolaire à rome
c'était eux qui expliquait comment l'as
tu es tu étais les ailes qui avait là
lance le pourquoi lequel était ce dieu
là où cette déesse là c'était un vrai
engagement en fait ça ça a changé un peu
le les outils là en l'occurrence avait
permis de changer l'engagement des
élèves leur maigre en question dans le
dans le court mais leur motivation mais
quand tu changes de la motivation d'un
enfant enfin toi qui est papa comme moi
mes filles et son peuple quand tu
changes de la motivation d'un enfant
après est capable de soulever des
montagnes parce que l'énergie le
positivisme le plaisir de s'épanouir
ça change je te regarde pas ça juste ça
use
on est avec and business france la
présence de la french tech ou bête à
londres alors salut c'est quoi l'idée
aujourd'hui d'être présent dans le cadre
du belle série événement éducation au
fric alors mal et deux en fait
un événement qui
en fait il est très important parce
qu'il nous permet d'aider les
entreprises françaises
à se développer à l'international sur un
événement
il est vraiment
mais peut-être
britanniques mais hors pair d'accord ok
donc c'est pas le profil d'un start up
que vous accompagnez ici et ben alors
aujourd'hui on a plusieurs
on a plusieurs certains pendant la
campagne une vingtaine donc des sociétés
des pme innovantes comme it up et puis
aussi des start up qui
qui qui sont plus petites et qui eux
amis quand pendant la durée du salon
s'ils viennent chercher du financement
ils viennent chercher du financement
mais aussi des clients
et tadic internationaux est aussi
français parce que la particularité de
ce salon en fait c'est que
on a beaucoup d'étrangers mais on avait
énormément français qui
m ça peut paraître surprenant mais c'est
le cas finalement dans beaucoup
d'événements donc on a beaucoup de
recteur qui viennent beaucoup
attitude
question en tout cas
de l'éducation française qui sont là et
puis voilà nous
pareil avec ces entreprises là grâce au
partenariat réussi qu'on a avec eux avec
la fenêtre et avec le ministère de
l'éducation nationale les aides
finalement à faire venir les entreprises
[Musique]
longtemps on a un tout nouveau style et
qui est dispo pour la surface groupe
pour tous les sens pas ce que vous
voulez écoute vachement moins cher la
prise en main est franchement cool et
surtout au niveau tarif il coûte 39 99
et ça franchement c'est imbattable pour
la prise de notes c'est franchement
hyper cool comme vous le voyez je décris
toujours aussi bien c'est franchement
hyper appréciable
notre mission c'est permettre à chacun à
chaque personne chaque organisation de
réaliser son plein potentiel et je crois
que l'éducation c'est bah c'est le
moment où tu peux rater des virages ou
au contraire les prendre dire donc c'est
un moment qui est perçu comme dans la
vie de chacun à un moment on a envie de
contribuer on attendait donc de
s'impliquer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il faut bien comprendre aujourd'hui
c'est que la plupart des métiers que
font les jeunes demain n'existe pas
aujourd'hui donc il faut bien les
inventer il faut bien les découvrir il
faut permettre aux jeunes générations de
s'exprimer pour pouvoir justement
prendre les choses en main pour
travailler sur tout est question de
l'intelligence artificielle est question
de numérique a énormément de choses très
intéressantes ont commencé entre
apercevoir
c'est une espèce de nébuleuse qui
emprunte de
s'éclaircir en convoi est ce qui est
vraiment passionnant c'est que la
révolution est en marche et au travers
d'un truc comme ça qui en fait est un
petit joystick ça permet de voir le
monde
susan eng
moi ce que je retiens principalement
parce que c'est vraiment une découverte
la première fois que je viens ici aux
bêtes c'est une nouvelle façon de voir
l'enseignement au royaume uni vous avez
24 écoles pilotes le truc est juste
hallucinant on a pu parler justement
avec un enseignant de l'école pilote et
communique avec les parents par twitter
enfin tout est complètement digitalisées
n'auront pas non plus dans les excès
l'idée ce n'est pas la machine qui va
enseigner sont vraiment les enseignants
mais qui s'appuie sur de nouveaux
supports je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez est ce que ça vous parle de cette
idée ce concept justement de révolution
de l'éducation
est-ce que vous pensez que microsoft va
réussir à changer le monde microsoft et
d'autres sont pas les seuls acteurs sur
le marché est ce que vous pensez qu'ils
vont réussir à changer le monde au
travers d' éducation ça prendra du temps
en tout cas les outils sont là c'est
vraiment intéressant moi je suis hyper
enthousiaste soit vraiment hyper cool
donc on en reparlera très très
prochainement dites moi ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire et puis est
ce que vous êtes parent est ce que du
coup vous projetez est ce que c'est
encore dans l'enseignement tout c'est
est ce que c'est quelque chose qui
pourrait vous plaire d'apprendre en
jouant minecraft et si vous veniez plus
si vous n'êtes pas par où est ce que
c'est un truc qui vous aurait parlé à
l'époque voilà je vous invite à marquer
tout ça en bas on en reparle vous laisse
et puis ce rendez-vous dès demain pour
une nouvelle aventure
non